[Music]
give health to cristian cásseres with his
informative radio station news now in spanish
a fire was reported between las vegas and
program that forced the evacuation of those
who were camping in that area the fire
known as cee andy bell and fire
consumed around a thousand  500 acres
since it started around
noon on Thursday officials
say this fire was caused by
humans but they are still investigating the
exact cause no injuries were reported and it
did not damage any property or
nearby residences
and viva las vegas the golden knights are
They go to the semifinals of the
professional hockey league after winning a
victorious matchup against the
Colorado team. The Nice played a
full house in the Bovine Timo. The
Avalanch scored their first goal in the
first 23 seconds of the game and a
minute later the Knights scored.  and they
managed to win 6 to 3 the knights will
face the dressing rooms on Monday the
first game of the semifinal
and the state  io elijen is running
anti-hobbit evacuation clinics
the effort began on thursday and will
run through sunday for a
period of two weeks appointments will
start at
2pm however you can also attend
without an appointment people will get  the
vaccine inside the stadium and they
will also receive a surprise gift and
the heat relief will end this Friday
we will have temperatures in the high 90
degrees but temperatures are expected to rise
this weekend
we will return to triple digits next
week and have  Be very careful because the
temperatures will be very dangerous.
Remember to stay hydrated and not
be exposed to the sun for several hours.
I am Cristian Cásseres with your
informative test of News Now in Spanish, a
good day
[Music]